tomorrow Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer returned
to the White House for a meeting with
President Trump now this time it's about
an infrastructure deal but in a moment
I'm gonna tell you what the showdown is
really all about and today the guy who
spent eight years working there Jill
Biden he tried mightily to convince you
that this time he has all the answers
but what's in his pitch in this
phenomenal Trump economy I think we have
to I am he got to rethink how we define
what constitutes a successful economy he
can barely get the words out there well
that's convenient right if you can't
beat him as in Trump's economic numbers
just change the way everything is scored
because by traditional metrics I'm
talking GDP wage growth unemployment
numbers in the stock market Trump should
be a lock for 2020 whether you like his
tone or not or his tweets the president
has beaten almost every target set by
the so called economic experts speaking
of so-called experts Nobel laureate Paul
Krugman he predicted an economic
apocalypse a global recession after
Trump's election well what happened to
that here's today's headline in Forbes
sorry Paul and what could we expect
though under a President Biden what will
he deliver well say goodbye to America
first trade policies that are working
Biden was a big advocate for that
boondoggle known as the trans-pacific
partnership that would have offshore
jobs to places like Malaysia and Vietnam
bye-bye to the tariffs that have forced
cheating countries at the table and
Biden would ditch all the protections
for American workers found in deals like
the u.s. MCA so if you're one of the
450,000 Americans with a new
manufacturing job your future will be
far from certain under Biden but
remember Joe pledges to bring you
dignity the dignity of work is my
measure which is about being able to
provide security
and share the joys with your families
the definition of dignity is that people
should never be treated as a means to an
end but an end in themselves when I
think about work I think about dignity I
think about a lot about my dad
a proud gentle man my dad had an
expression he said Joey a job is about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
of course he fails to respect the tight
labor market that Trump's policies have
helped create what does that do that
helps with restoring dignity because
workers wages are finally going up more
money in your pocket more time to spend
with your family and now that all those
dire predictions they all failed now
that things are going so well
well Biden has to kind of throw magic
reality altering dust in the air to
convince you that this isn't one of the
best times ever to be an American who
was willing to work and by the way it is
well chopped of course has an easy
response to that remember President
Obama said manufacturing jobs a gun you
need a wand a magic wand we found the
magic wand because they're coming and
they're coming fair I love the fact that
wages are rising fastest for the lowest
income Americans the percentages and
we're now the number one economy
anywhere in the world and it's not even
close
a little different from the Biden rally
today but now it's time to deal with
Chuck and Nancy because they're back at
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue tomorrow with a
framework for a massive infrastructure
package remember last month at a
democrat retreat Pelosi floated a price
tag of two trillion dollars Democrats
also want to expand the definition of
what infrastructure is beyond in other
words fixing bridges roads and airports
to include things like enhancing
broadband water systems schools and
housing why not why stop there and
predictably Democrats want the cost to
be borne by people meaning you by doing
what
raising taxes of course well it's a
non-starter for this president because
he believes a tax hike will slow this
red-hot economy and of course betray his
campaign promises to be a tax cutter my
question is this will there be any big
kumbaya moment imagine if they were
swaying back and forth tomorrow
caught on camera either during or after
the confab well look it's hard to
imagine any cooperative spirit given how
their last meetup went down if we don't
have border security we're not gonna
keep it on let me cheat we want to do
the same thing we did last year this
year Chuck we can build up a match to
figure that's debated okay yeah let's
debate in private we came in here in
good faith and and and we're entering
into a this kind of a discussion in the
public it's not fair there's you know a
new cold transparency that's called
transparency
let's close the doors keep the reporters
out my friends make no mistake this
whole routine tomorrow is as much about
setting the narrative for 2020 as it is
about getting something done that is
traditionally a bipartisan effort
infrastructure if infrastructure
spending can pay for itself by
stimulating the economy creating its own
revenue stream well I guess you can make
the argument for it but if not we
shouldn't do the infrastructure spending
at least not right
now Democrats and Republicans are
addicted to spending your money albeit
they have different priorities
Republicans remember were itching to
bust those Obama era spending caps to
jack up military spending
they thought it was justified in
Democrats well they're fine on spending
money we don't have on stuff like green
energy free college free preschool free
everything we are announcing the most
ambitious climate plan in the history of
the United States that means mobilizing
five trillion dollars we are going to
deliver a Medicare for All single-payer
system make college universally
available with free tuition and fees we
will guarantee that right with universal
pre-k and debt-free college there's no
end to the spending but this my friends
is the National Debt Clock and it's
obscene that we are doing this to future
generations
everybody talks I know about modifying
entitlements changing them reforming
them but no one ever does anything about
it Axios reported today by the way that
Chuck and Nancy are carefully though
preparing for this meeting tomorrow with
the president but they want to do it in
order to gain maximum political benefit
their true aim is to set up whomever the
Democratic nominee is as the defender of
the working men and women against the
rich executives and considering Biden's
performance today he needs all the help
he can get it's not just for people who
get to four-year college degrees but
those who compete for job training and
trades and programs look guys we can do
all this and that's the angle